he big is the what he big is the Super
Bowl but the difference is it's just two
guys playing that they did in the
studio
Andy the song is kind of like an incel
Anthem and a commentary even on the
notion of an incel right it opens up
with some guy just playing video games
firsters shooter video games says yeah
I'm playing the video games I'm playing
all these video games and I'm really
good I'm really good at the video games
I'm this is bigger than the Super Bowl
yeah even though we're just and we're
just two guys in the studio but I'm
really really good so he's building up
his ego based on nothing including the
first of all the video games don't
really translate into anything that
matters in the real world they can be
fun they're fun Recreation but if if you
make that a core aspect of your identity
then you're going to feel bad about
yourself because it doesn't really
matter all that much it's just a game
it's just a
passing pleasure